I guess could come be compared to what
Trump saying he's I mean he's basically
he's getting restless over the the
social distancing and the people working
from home it seems like he's already
trying to get people to go back to work
her already like the White House is is
talking about already people going back
to work how does that contrast with what
your government's telling you in the UK
was completely laughs today's achill
Boris Johnson came out and made an
announcement a couple of weeks ago
saying that we weren't gonna like the
country downs business as usual it needs
to spread so that we can get herd
immunity but once they saw the numbers
coming out of Italy in Spain and saw the
by not locking the country down our
trajectory was a steeper incline than
those countries but just running two
weeks behind they've realized now
they've had to implement these measures
and what the u.s. just jump into 200
deaths in one day you guys are on that
trajectory as well
even worse scenario than us right now
looking at the numbers what does it look
like on the streets there what are
people doing like your friends people
you talk to is is it like a desert Ville
just like New York City so there are
various stages of lockdown in the
European countries so in Italy in Spain
where they are putting the corpses in
the churches because they can't there's
nowhere to put them anymore
and they're throwing blankets over
people who are dying in the corridors
those guys now if you leave your house
you're going to get a huge fine here in
the UK we've got Paris Johnson telling
us just stay at home stay at home you
know there's going to be police problems
coming if people don't obey this so
we're not on a strict a lockdown as the
Italians to go out of your house and
it's the right now you require requires
a paper paperwork mm-hmm and you've got
this three specific reasons you can
leave your house and if you can't tell
the police you're doing one of those
reasons you get a fine on the spot well
maybe even imprisonment yeah and I guess
this it's it's worse in different parts
of
is that right I guess Milan is the worst
of all and I believe you actually talked
to a girl from Milan yeah there are
various parts of Italy that have been
affected much worse than others so
that's the other thing you know I post a
video saying that it's like this in this
area and then people really say oh well
there's nothing happening here you know
this is all hype and it's just crazy the
way people are reacting what the same
thing happened with the Spanish flu if
you look at the cities in America were
the leaders and the business owners said
it was all hype and refused to lock down
they got the most deaths and the cities
that he did the advice that it was
coming and locked down they got the
least deaths so there's a dilemma
between the economy now and saving lives
[Laughter]